today Ronin in me we want to share our
experiences and best practices about pi
sprack before starting with the
visitation is noted that this
presentation is actually intended for
very experienced and immediate to
experienced audience so we expect from
you some kind of experience with price
Park and spark in general this is a plan
for today so first of all I would give a
short introduction into PI sport then
runner would talk about data structures
and configuration and performance and
then I'm going to talk about unit
testing with PI spark data pipeline
management and then runner will give a
example about how you could use the
streaming API in PI sport and finally I
will talk a little bit how you're able
to put your models into production so
what is actually high spec I mean if you
attended the earlier session was to say
before you probably know this graph so I
will go through this very quickly well
in app iceberg when you actually do when
you start a PI spark application you
actually create a spark context and this
spark context actually use private J to
create the JVM on the master node and
the must know the JVM actually invokes a
spark workers on the remote machines and
this remote machines actually uses
starts the Python sub processes and uses
pipe to communicate with them as Aria
also already set in the last
presentation from from this graph you
already can see that in comparison to
scholar or Java there will be also
additional cost incurred because every
time you you start the PI spark
application you actually have to also
create the path and sub processes so
there will always be additional time
involved with this another important
point is actually that series Asian
happens in both the Python subprocesses
and also the JVM this is
there's no cost another important point
I think I don't know if you here are
apparent appointed to this out is
actually the Python memory occasion is
actually not controlled by the JVM so
for example if you have very reasonable
settings and yawn and something this
that makes total sense
you would still get some out of memory
area because of this situation but this
is something that Ronald will go more
into detail
yeah let's review quickly review some of
the core data structures in spark so
first of all there are rdd's these are
resilient distributed data sets and what
they do is these these are really a
distributed collection fault tolerant
collection of items and and they're
they're a lazy data structure and there
are two kinds of operations on those
transformations and actions
transformations are always lazy they
only get executed once an action is
performed on them and and that enables
spark to chain operations together and
run optimizations on those next up are
data frames data frames are built on top
of rdd's they are essentially a
collection of rows with some schema
information and these are mostly these
are mostly kept in a JVM and once once
you perform PI spark API operations on
them all those operations get compiled
to native Java bytecode which is a huge
huge performance boost and a notable
exception is Python UDF's so if you DF
is a user-defined function and if you if
you execute execute those user-defined
functions on a data frame what will
happen is what what that talked about
the PI for J has to communicate was a
JVM and start
realizing and deserializing object so
it's a lot slower again and that's why
you should always use native native
Python objects sorry in native native
function calls on these data frames
whenever possible
and one last tip when using data frames
is you should use always use the hive
context and not the standard sequel
context you don't even need the hive
install to use this but you get a lot
more window functions and a lot more
functionality in in general and yeah
this is a benchmark comparing RDD
performance to data frame performance
and what you can see here when you look
at the rdd's Scalla is actually a lot
faster than python
whereas with data frames all the various
api is they have exactly the same
performance and that's because what I
talked about the compilation to to a
native Java bytecode now another
advantage of using data frames is that
you get this nice second syntax here and
so in most cases whenever you can use
data frames instead of LEDs you should
use those as much as possible then there
is a third new data structure in in pi
spark and spark in general data sets
this this came in spark 1.6 they will
actually be merged with data frames in
spark 2.0 there are statically Tides
essentially data frames but they're
statically typed it's an idea taken from
the Apache flink project and what that
means is that restricting the space of
what can be expressed further enables
many more optimizations similar to what
the MPP database is able to do and will
speed up spark a lot now the problem is
pythons of course not a statically typed
language so it's unclear yet whether we
can we even will even get to be able to
use data sets in in pi spark and maybe
as Jose here in the front row proposed
earlier today we will end up
having to use the Scala API if we want
to use if we want to use SPARC to its
fullest okay and most the most difficult
part actually of of at least in our
experience of running SPARC is
configuration and performance tuning and
there's not a lot of material regarding
running PI SPARC on a real production
cluster out there so we want to give you
some hints on how to configure configure
SPARC actually my speaker notes are not
working there's a lot of math here so
let me just let me just try to fix that
one second okay okay that did it
alright so when configuring SPARC
there's actually a order of precedence
the the place where there's a highest
precedence when configuring SPARC is if
you set it programmatically in during
during your Pythons during your PI spark
script so if you run a spark on it
overrides all of the other settings both
the options you pass in the command line
and the options you you pass in your
configuration scripts of SPARC second is
a command line so the command line
overrides anything that you set in your
configuration files and finally you you
have your configuration files your spark
defaults and SPARC and the most
difficult part of configuring SPARC is
spark memory management now spark has
three memory regions there is a spark
storage memory this is where where all
of your cache data resides then you have
X
memory this is this is where spills and
shuffles and so on have their temporary
storage and you have user memory this is
this is where you can store a custom
data structures like hash maps and
things like that and then there's
reserve memory for the photo operating
system now before before spark 1.6 this
was a huge problem because there was
this barrier here between storage memory
and execution memory these were actually
a separate memory managers so if you
have a very long PI SPARC script or
general SPARC script and some parts of
your program require a lot of storage
memory whereas others require a lot of
execution memory there's always a
trade-off is there's no dynamic change
between the two so if you have a lot of
room in your storage memory but you need
more executors memory there's no way to
share that between the two and also
between programs for every single SPARC
program you have to optimize your
storage memory fraction now this has
grown away in 1.6 that the boundary is
dynamic now there's a single memory
manager for all of your SPARC memory
which is really cool because now you
need to spend much less time configuring
your SPARC memory usage what what's what
for us Pythian users is actually bad
though is that the Pythian memory is
still outside of all of this the SPARC
JVM does not control the past memory so
even if you tune this perfectly you
still might go out of memory on your in
your SPARC processes and exactly so now
now in 1.6 this this whole thing has
become a lot simpler and actually on the
internet if you had to find a good
simple worked example of configuring a
spark cluster 4 PI SPARC so we spend a
lot of time trying to figure this out
what are the optimal values so I want to
quickly walk you through a worked
example of how to properly configure a
spark cluster to run pi SPARC as an
example we will take a 6 node cluster
with 6
course on each node and 64 gigabytes of
RAM for each node the first thing we
need to do is we need to set our basic
yarn config if we were running this on
top of yarnís I think most people do we
set it to 61 gigabytes of yarn RAM to
leave a little bit of room for the
operating system and we also leave one
of one of the cores for the for the
operating system and an associated
processes and next up we actually need
to do the SPARC configuration now it's a
fairly good idea to over commit your
executors by about 1.5 and this is to
avoid under utilization of the cluster
from a network i/o and general hard disk
i/o wait and you actually get the
optimal HDFS throughput this has been a
benchmarked and measured by cloud era
with roughly 5 or 6 executors course so
here 4 times 6 gives you 24 and and 24
divided by 16 from our 16 cores gives
you this 1.5 over commit ratio now now
as I've mentioned before Python are the
Python memories managed outside of all
of this and each executors core has his
own Python process by default this is
512 megabytes so now you have to when
you configure your cluster you have to
keep in mind that you need to allocate
memory for python so we have 25 24
concurrent python processes on each on
each of the worker nodes so that leaves
us with 11,000 600 megabytes of
executors memory if you don't keep this
in mind you may very easily run out of
get run into some mysterious out of
memory errors if you run past Park again
anybody has any questions yes
also so you have for each executor yeah
you have you have 24 - processes right
so that may be let me see if is yeah
this comes up so you have 24 pison
processes each of those has 12 12
hundred megabytes of ram by default
right and then you have for your JVM you
have four executors and each of those
executors gets eleven six out eleven
thousand six hundred megabytes of RAM so
that gives you roughly fifty nine
gigabytes of allocated RAM which is a
little bit of two gigabytes of headroom
for yours should give a little bit of
space for you to avoid out of memory
errors does that answer your question
okay and if you do need more of Python
Emery so for simple data processing 512
megabytes of RAM is enough but there are
some cases say you're a multinational
company and you want to calculate many
parallel models for each of the regions
you operate and using scikit-learn and
you're going to use your PI spark
cluster to paralyze scikit-learn now now
if you want to be a run scikit-learn 512
megabytes of ram is not going to be
enough so if you do run out of paths and
out of memory errors what you can do is
you reduce the concurrency and if you
reduce your concurrency of less python
processes per executor and then you can
allocate more more ram to each of those
so in our example if we reduce reduce
the whole thing to four executors per
node was four executors course that
leaves us with a gigabyte of ram for a
python process and a little bit or less
for the JVM and we can keep reducing
that so we had some use cases where we
left for six gigabytes of RAM for Python
if we want to fit fairly large models
other useful settings we have
encountered when running your PI spark
and practice is you can save substantial
memory if you turn compression on that's
a simple simple true flag here and also
also you if you run it on a cluster
especially a large cluster you should
tor turn a speculative execution on I
really don't know why it's not the
default it just means if there's a very
slow worker it will relaunch that task
for that worker on one that has some
some free CPU cycles so then if you have
a dying node or something that will work
around that and finally if you're using
Python free like we do there's actually
a huge problem if you're running it in a
distributed environment it will fail on
operations like group by key because
Python 3 has a new security feature it's
it introduces a random hash seed for
each Python process and add throws of Pi
spark so you actually need to set the
spark executors environmental to some
fixed hash seed what about performance
tuning so so one thing that you should
never forget is to cash your rdd's
you're going to read reuse and you
always set this memory and disk I have
seen no use case yet where it would make
sense to just do memory only and disk
only be interested to hear if there are
some use cases but we're probably not
and say you're say you're running across
you're using your PI spark cluster to
run cross-validation or a grid search or
something you're going to reuse the same
set of data many many times if you do
not cache the data before you run your
cross-validation what will happen is
that spark is not smart enough to figure
out you want to reuse that data so it's
going to evict it for memory and then
you have to recompute all your features
from scratch and that takes a lot of
time so always cache your data avoid
group by key on rdd's it's super slow
it's it's a throws a lot of out of
memory errors and it's generally not a
good idea if you do need to group
something by key then use data frames
because they use this native JVM
bytecode and a lot of lot faster for
this operation and finally if you need
if you do need to run a group operation
like the scikit-learn models i was
talking about the parallel there's one
feature that's new in 1.6 I don't think
enough
people know about you can actually
partition your data by key now so if you
load the data set into spark say from
parquet or something you can tell it ok
I know what what kiowa group this data
set by at a later stage so why not
already a shuffle distributed over my
cluster by that key so if I do that
group operation there will be no
shuffles at all so that's a really handy
tip and finally there's tree we use tree
aggregate you can use instead of reduce
and aggregate because via run reduce
then everything will be sent to a single
node and this will become the bottleneck
whereas using tree reduce intermediate
results will be spread amongst the
workers and it's generally a better
function and finally if you're using a
small data sets like a lookup table or
something always broadcast that so all
the nodes have that available it's also
can speed up your programs a lot ok on
to a unit testing all right so let's
start with a literate call me can you
read this actually right so as you can
see here's their PhDs turn with this
professor and obviously he's not a data
site and not a computer scientist so he
wrote some code which is in Oregon which
is messy right and actually who have you
had a PhD or did a PhD alright so maybe
some of you know the situation and this
actually works quite well in academia
but in production when you put your code
in production or have a very huge code
base it's very difficult because you
spend a lot of time in debugging your
code and actually the solution to this
is actually TDD so who have you know
what TDD is ok some pretty cool so TDD
is actually one of the core practices to
add Perl apps and well I don't probably
don't need to explain what it is right
so you write your tasks first right as
minimum as possible code to have the
test pass and
then you refactor your code so far this
has worked pretty well for our sub
engineers but in terms of data science
it is quite difficult so the reality is
difficult for us as well because as a
data scientist there's some so has a
component in our work right because when
we start with a problem and we do some
modeling we are not quite sure whether
we're going to use this model or not and
we ask the sub engineer it's much easier
because you know you you you broken an
app you know what kind of features you
have read so writing things it's much
easier and what we do is actually we
divide it our project in two phases so
we have an exploration phase and a
production phase and what you're doing
an exploration phase is we experiment
with a lot of models we use an iPad
notebook and and then during this face
we also know what we want to test and in
the production phase we were starting to
put things into scripts right because in
the scripts you can use more
automatically and there we also start to
write the test first and for doing for
testing app iceberg application we are
actually basically just using unit tests
and single notes back application and
what important note would is that we are
for testing we're mocking our data
because this is what you actually do in
unit test because the test should fail
fast or very slow this is actually an
example how test could look like so this
is a clustering example so first of all
you you convert your data frame right
and usually and k-means you you probably
also rescale your data and then you you
assign your cluster and then you can
break from the expiration face you know
how the data structure look looks like
and then you just collect you have some
kind of output that you're already
expected and then what you do is you can
implement the code like this way so far
it's just so minimum because what you
can do is you can take the variables
from K and the scene and so on outside
the function
so like refactoring your code but this
is how this is a minimal code that would
have
test pass basically the whole example
can be found on my repo so if you want
to check it would be cool if you're
gonna check out it another important
topic that I want to talk about is data
pipeline we had a data pipeline topic
earlier they actually wrote their own
yeah pipeline management anyway so
usually the pipeline management where we
just solve it for it can be quite
difficult right because you have a lot
of dependencies usually usually in a in
a machine learning or in a data science
project you have two phases right so you
you you get some data from a database or
you get data from from from anywhere and
then you process it ATAR and then you
fit a model on that and then maybe after
the modeling you will store your model
on the on a database and basically for
one project it it's quite okay but when
time goes by you might have more
projects at more use cases and chaining
all of them can be quite difficult so
what did we do in the past in the past
actually rewrote our own Python Python
pipeline with Python and in this case we
actually change sequel and and and the
the PI spark code together but one of
the disadvantage of this approach is
when you do Spock submit and the master
node you actually have to distribute all
your code to all the remote work
machines this can be quite a hassle
because for example if you changed a lot
from your code you have to do this every
time and and and upload everything to
your remote working machines another
important point is logger so logger is
is a module for for tour logging is very
powerful but you can also spend a lot of
time customizing it so this is also I'm
not a very good so that's why what we
did is we switch Luigi as where earlier
presentation or a test or a said Luigi
is developed by Spotify it's 100% Python
code it comes with a web dashboard you
have parallel workers
you have a central scheduler and the
cool thing is actually you have
parameters so you can pass parameters in
each test which is quite handy so this
is actually basically an example for for
in Wichita so what you do is you you you
import the Spock summit class and then
what I just set you can define some
parameters like date and number of case
which you can actually pass to your
script and what you also can do here is
you can set up your craft dependencies
right in this case for example the
future engineering task has to run first
before the clustering task can run and
basically Luigi works like make a make
but this yeah and also what we usually
do which is we don't run it like all the
settings programmatically or or in the
command line but we set up in the client
config file and then when you run which
it will actually read all the SPARC
conflicts from from Luigi and with Luigi
it actually changed the structure so
when you do now SPARC submit you
actually don't need to distribute all
the Python or sequence [ __ ]
everything in the Python path within the
remote worker machines anymore but Luigi
is actually taken care of it of course
there are some disadvantages that comes
with Luigi so for example you still have
to use cron jobs to trigger your job so
there's no built in there are other
things like air flow which does it but
it's not as lightweight as Luigi another
thing that I want to mention is that
documentation could actually better so
would be cool if you have time and then
you can also contribute to the Luigi
project and also logging is quite okay
in a Luigi so there's there's no much to
do but the problem is when you set
multiple workers you get a lot of
logging and disabling it's not very easy
and another thing is when you have a lot
of tasks because it's a nature of it
because you have a lot of probably use
cases like this you will have to
duplicate all the parameters within the
test and for example if you have one a
test
you have to take care of this 100
parameters okay so online learning with
spice park streaming um this is actually
not another really how-to or in practice
it's more something I want to put your
attention to and this is something
that's more recently came out in one
spark 1.5 from 1.6 and using sparks
stream processing primitives combined
with saw online learning capabilities
that came to the ML Lib library using
some stochastic gradient descent based
methods we can create real time machine
learning models that we can update on
new data as it streams in and arrives so
at the moment there's only streaming
linear regression and streaming k-means
but there's more coming and under the
hood it uses just it's actually the code
if you if you pull it and have a look at
the code base actually fairly simple it
just uses for each RTD and map under the
hood and but this enables a lot of
really cool use cases so we can keep one
model or set of models always up-to-date
on multiple on new data as it streams in
so these models can quickly adapt to new
situations or contexts and another
useful applications is to track the
performance of the models in an online
manner and that enables you to for
example run a be test with Bayesian
bandit models or something like that in
real time so only if you say if you have
two recommender systems and even more
and you can you can evaluate them in
real time and as you monitor the
performance you only start to expose the
best model to your customers and this is
just like a real time a
the testing an optimization with no
manual intervention and you can also
monitor the the models performance in
real-time so you can respond respond to
changes if the performance starts with
some knee drop one downside of online
learning in in pi spark and spark in
general is that the latency is fairly
low so you never get under one second
latency using a spark this is because it
operates on mini-batches and not on
individual items in a stream and that's
why that's why it's not really ideal to
expose an API or something like this
using spark streaming fling looks very
promising in that regard but it doesn't
have a very comprehensive Python API at
or machine learning library okay on to
operationalization well since we don't
have so much time with make it quite
fast so so one of the approaches really
actually taking is API first so for
everything that we do we try to write an
API as fast as possible and to doing so
we are using flash which probably all of
you know and this example what we do is
we train our model in PI spark then we
store it on reddit so some for some for
example like or you can also do it on
HDFS and then we write a pretty function
to make use of this model and this is
actually a very simple post method that
we use to post data and then we import
it from the requests and then we use to
predict or assigned clustering function
to to get the labels vary this is
something that we want to talk with it
more because so flash is actually pretty
cool but you cannot use it into
production right and for using things
into production if you saw the Palladium
talk yesterday they are using marathon
and we are using we are actually using
Cloud Foundry so clear phone tree is a
platform as a service service and what
you can do is you should sneak your code
it could be any code could be Java could
be scholar you just use you do is just
do CF push you define you
manifests which is kind of instruction
and then you do CF push and that ever
this will push it to the cloud and we'll
take everything carefully for you from
you so we would take care of load
balancing updating your code security
and many things actually there's a try
version so you can test it out for two
months and there's also examples how you
could use flats with pivot country from
one of my colleagues so yeah check it
out that's it Thanks okay so we have
time for some questions we only have
this one microphone so I would ask you
to repeat the question so that they can
be recorded over here we haven't done
that I saw oh sorry repeat the question
so the question is Python can be slower
can perform slower when using PI spark
and is there a possibility to use
directly call up JVL java code or
scholar called i guess from python right
to speed up processing we haven't done
that yeah I saw talk and PI data
Amsterdam though from olden Krakow she
she gave an example of doing this but I
haven't tried it out yet
so the question was when should you say
and I can't use Python anymore I have to
use Scala or Java due to performance
reasons or features well that's a hard
question to answer it depends on on what
you want to do and when I mean when when
you you had enough there's no hard and
fast rules yes at the moment the
performance difference is not that huge
even if we if we go back to this
benchmark here even if you're using
rdd's and not data frames I mean it
really depends on your problem right so
there's some something like some
features in in Scala that you don't have
in in Python and and and also it's a
trade-off between speed of doing things
and having performance even if you're
using RTD so in the worst case I mean
you you you get about a two or threefold
degradation of performance I think
that's fine but things might change with
the data set API that's coming right
there's going to be a lot faster and we
might not get that empire's installed on
yard we might actually have to switch
this SCADA or if desk gets more mature
rights which would ask so more questions
anyone thanks for the talk have you
considered on an on your unit test to
use some fuzzing library to to feet
random data or do you just use static
data at the moment we just use static
data but
actually there is what is called this
hypothesis library from that comes from
Haskell's testing framework I would
really like to have a look at that but
we haven't done that in practice yet
yeah we also have to figure it out
because if you always use randomized
dater
you always have to change the output as
well thanks for your talk
I have a configuration question for some
reason my driver starts on on one of the
slave nodes not on the master notes next
to the executor by default
do you have similar problems or no so so
I have to adjust CP course for the
driver and I'm so so it fits on
executors what framework are you execute
yeah I don't know what what what
framework are using is this is on the
yarn or on mezzos or onion that's a
stack stack overflows yeah sure
so we have experiences okay are there
more questions okay
you showed um using unit testing that's
something I'm trying to do quite a bit
as well and I found it's kind of
non-trivial to get hold of a spark
context and to work with packages and
stuff like that I've been using um spark
testing base which in turn uses fine
spark but yeah do you have any tips on
how to get hold of the spark context how
to make sure ya could just work I know
there's an environment variable you can
supposedly set for yes but so what the
important thing is when you do the unit
testing with iceberg a very handy tip is
actually also to shut down the logging
so like of like from logging from info
to error and because because when you
use PI spark you will get a lot of Java
code and also a lot of Python respect as
well so which is also going
and what you really want is here
that's reporters running example of so
if you use that you will work cool thank
you so actually you are you on a neck
yeah yeah so actually what you need to
do is just to approve install apache
spark and then define the full path in
the environment and then just clone the
repo and then it's going to work cool
thank you this so there's a readme okay
i would propose that we said a coffee
break and whoever has more questions
walks out to the speakers so let's thank
them again thanks